hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcasting
ah just checking in on you
checking to see how your week's going
are you taking care of yourself
uh i'm trying to after my [ __ ] desert
excursion
that was it for me i'm just like all
right you know what
i think it's time i [ __ ] shut it down
shut it down taking some inventory here
in march
um i was trying to go like all right let
me try like this you know these people
these plant-based diets
you know these poor people [ __ ]
taking a [ __ ] every 20 minutes
you know but their skin is cleared up
right so like all right i'll give this a
i'll give this a try so i lasted uh
let's see what's today march 3rd
yeah today i had an italian sandwich
um i was gonna [ __ ] i don't know i
don't know what the [ __ ] i was gonna do
and i just said ah you know what
once a week can i just eat an animal
you know can i just do that can i just
[ __ ]
can't i just have that um
i have my little soda pop it's all i got
left right it's all i got left
um no i've got a kind of uh
a little mushroom trip you know
that really just made me think oh no
this is not about the people around me
this is
this is how i feel about myself so i'm
gonna try to take care of myself
at least for the [ __ ] month we'll see
we'll see without bringing you guys down
or whatever so i've been you know
looking up
plant-based dinners and [ __ ] and it's
really like nutrition is
probably trying to figure out what the
right answer is
you know like i was that [ __ ] guy i
mean god bless him he's shredded he
looks like he's making
a [ __ ] ton of money but he goes
cardio burns fat
right no cardio burns calories and it's
like you could run
seven miles a day you're not gonna burn
yes you are you are you're gonna be
[ __ ]
real thin i'm not saying you won't lose
muscle too but like what's been [ __ ]
me over is no cardio
cardio kept my stomach flat
i don't know what the [ __ ] and every
[ __ ] three days it's just like
butter gives you a heart attack [ __ ]
drizzle as much as you can in your
coffee
so i don't know what to believe
you know and i'm not listening to some
guy in the prime of his life who
shredded
i was shredded when i was [ __ ] you
know the first half of my 20s i was
shredded
jesus christ you're in your 20s
i want to see a [ __ ] 52 year old
[ __ ] bald ginger like me going cardio
burns fat
right no cardio burns fat right no
right then i'll listen to that guy i'm
not gonna [ __ ] listen to some guy
with a full head of hair
not a gray hair on his head it's like
who i don't know who he's talking he
ain't talking to me
all right i want to listen to somebody
who needs to stretch for 45 minutes it
can only
[ __ ] work out for six minutes that's
you know
i miss richard simmons you know you just
put on some candy stripe he stayed in
shape didn't he he used to be a fatty
look at him
put on his little peppermint shorts and
he [ __ ] got the old ladies up out of
their wheelchairs and
you know everybody felt a little better
um
i don't know but i've been doing these
banned workouts right oh god i'm so
[ __ ] old and i love them
i love them they're great my shoulders
feel
normal now they feel actually like
they're getting stronger finally i
finally uh got to somebody who helped me
crack the code here so i'm just going to
sort of work my way up to that
and uh i think that's what i'm going to
do for the for the remainder of my years
is i'm just going to do like ban workout
and it's actually
not that bad you throw some push-ups in
there a couple of setups you can do
squats and [ __ ] like that
and uh you know then you don't have to
go to a gym
but i have to watch what i eat because
i'm not doing cardio
no i'm not doing cardio so i'm not
burning enough [ __ ] calories
i need it in my hope like
i look at my body like yeah that's what
the [ __ ] i need to do and then every
every [ __ ] youtube video i watch this
kid comes on shredded with a full head
of hair no gray hair telling me i don't
need it
all right bill relax okay sorry whatever
it's late in the [ __ ] day what do you
want from me
um i just watched the uh bruins losing
the shootout
to the uh formidable washington capitals
who look like uh you know islanders look
good but they look
clearly like the best team in our
division we got him again
on friday and uh if you're into hockey
fights i would definitely watch
trent frederick and tom wilson frederick
is [ __ ] hilarious
he was trying to fight ovechkin it was
like eventually i'm not [ __ ] fighting
you
but then he [ __ ] kept cross-checking
him and pissing him off
that finally ovechkin like slashed him
and they and they
they he got him off the ice you know
um i think frederick got two for
interference
and ovechkin got two for roughing and
you know he did his job he got one of
the best players in the league
off the ice and we traded that for trent
frederick so towards the end of the game
i think tom wilson
let frederick know that uh there's gonna
be repercussions for that action
and i gotta tell you that frederick does
not back down and he [ __ ] with two of
the toughest guys
in the league man i mean ovechkin for a
goal scorer
he [ __ ] some kid challenged him a few
years ago and it was just a
one punch scary knockout
okay i don't know what i mean
i'm gonna be watching that frederick
versus wilson fight i'm obviously bruin
fan i'm rooting for trent frederick but
i'm gonna watch that with [ __ ]
one-eyed shut
because uh wilson is no joke and um
just blatant disrespect to ovechkin that
whole game blatant
disrespect um pissing him off
[ __ ] doing all of this [ __ ] and it's
wilson's job to make sure that that [ __ ]
doesn't happen as their enforcer so
there's the backstory
and the game is on friday if you want to
[ __ ] check it out i also watched my
celtics
uh get a big win over the clippers
granted leonard wasn't playing but
[ __ ] jalen brown and paul george just
put on a
[ __ ] show um
effortless effortless i think
that after the first quarter i think
both teams had like 35 points they want
pace to score like 140 points
i forget what it ended they both ended i
was like 117 115
but um just a great game big win for the
celtics
um kind of was in this little bit of a
losing streak there obviously since
um marcus smart has been out um
and i know that leonard wasn't in so but
i'll take the [ __ ] victory the
celtics will take the goddamn victory
um oh but getting back one of the things
um if you're even listening to this
because my
[ __ ] internet's been screwed up
you know i love when you look up like i
try to look up
internet scams
um slow internet and then
the you just scroll through page after
page and all it does
is tell you what you can buy to speed up
your internet these [ __ ] pieces
of [ __ ] so then i had this look up
internet provider
find and then i found what i was looking
for
and that was that a t and t
got fined let me see if i can find it
here
ah christ what the [ __ ] was it they get
fined like you know
60 million in data throttling case
well it seems obvious it bears repeating
that internet providers must tell people
about any restrictions on the speed or
the amount of data
i think they just turn it down at the
[ __ ] office they try to pull this
[ __ ] with like well if everybody's using
it late at night
it's like everybody's using their cell
phones i can still [ __ ] talk on mine
what kind of technology are you guys
using i don't buy it
but you know there's no i don't know
whatever happened to the better business
bureau
they used to really go after people and
it meant something back in the day now i
just think i just gotta
i just feel like calling up my provider
and just being like look what the
[ __ ] amount of money do i have to give
you now
so you let my internet work you know i'm
doing podcasts here
i got no stand-up career left like what
the [ __ ] am i supposed to be doing over
here can you can you just turn up the
juice
um you know i asked my friends they're
all do little it's all about the
the router no whatever
speaking of router had [ __ ]
roto-rooter come over [ __ ] the other
day
roto-rooter that's the name and if you
[ __ ] [ __ ] won't go down the drain
we'll come over
i forget how the song goes right they
came over turns out i got [ __ ]
i got tree roots
tree roots and one of the [ __ ] i
don't know pipes that leads out of the
goddamn house
but god bless them god bless them that
they can stick something down there and
actually with the camera
see what's going on down there i can't
imagine jesus christ you know when they
sit there and they talk about you know
what happens if you watch
porn how bad it is for your brain
can you imagine if you watch porn and
you work for roto-rooter
and you're basically you know what do
they call that procedure where they
stick the camera up your ass
colonoscopy you know you're doing a
colonoscopy on a [ __ ] toilet
and you're going all the way down there
and there's tree roots blocking stuff
going i mean jesus christ i mean he
probably saw
you know there's probably [ __ ] down
there that ben franklin took
you know i don't know how old this
goddamn house is well ben franklin was
already dead right
did he drink himself to death
doesn't he kind of look like mario
batali you know except like more
patriotic
hang on a second uh let's see here ben
franklin
ben franklin ben franklin
let's see he lived oh
jesus he lived to be almost [ __ ] 84
years old
wow what a rich son he was a fat bastard
too
great jeans you know
he was confident as [ __ ] with his
[ __ ] receding hairline and the long
hair
he sort of had the hockey haircut you
know on the sides but up top he looks
like if you
put your thumb over where his long hair
is you're like if you had to guess you'd
be like accountant
politi is that rudy giuliani you know
benjamin franklin he was one of the
founding fathers of the united
states a polymath
he was a leading writer printer
politician philosopher
polit this is like what a blogger was
back then all the [ __ ] you had to learn
how to do
the [ __ ] is a polymath a polymath
having learned much is an individual
whose knowledge spans a substantial
number of subjects known to draw on
complete bodies of knowledge to solve
specific problems
the earliest recording recorded use of
the term
in english is from 1624
in the second edition of the anatomy of
melancholy
what in the [ __ ] is that
sounds like a smashing pumpkin album the
form
polly mathis is slightly older
so this is just a guy that knows a bunch
of [ __ ] he's like cliff clavin
if you fly a kite there with a key on it
let's see what this thing is
the anatomy of melancholy
what the [ __ ] is i thought it was a book
the anatomy of melancholy full title the
anatomy of melancholy what it is
with all kinds of causes symptoms
oh they're trying to people were bummed
out people were bummed out back then
the [ __ ] would you be bummed out about
a bear came in and ate your wife
probably if you were on the [ __ ]
at least the food was fresh if you could
find some right on its surface the book
is presented as a medical textbook
in which burton applies his vast and
varied learning
and the scholastic scholastic scholastic
scholastic matter to the subject of
melancholy
which includes although it's not limited
to
what is now term is clinical depression
wow
how the [ __ ] did i get to this on ben
franklin
although presented as a medical text the
anatomy of melancholy
is i would like if it isn't so [ __ ]
ye
and all of this old english is that a
good book
i want to see what the f what bummed
people out
back in the day you couldn't shoot an
arrow as straight as the other guy so
the chick you loved lifted up her giant
[ __ ] hoop skirt for somebody else
you had to put your horse down
wait what the [ __ ] did i go into that
founding fathers a polymath he was a
leading oh
i looked up polymath that's what it was
do you guys remember because i don't
[ __ ] remember how i got there
oh it was first recorded in the second
edition of the anatomy of melancholy
you know i think a lot of people who are
like depressed and [ __ ] do read a lot of
stuff because you're trying to shut off
all of that [ __ ] chatter in your head
you know until you do mushrooms and then
you're confronted with it
oh whoa billy desert was not expecting
that i mean i thought the [ __ ] you
know my socks were going to be talking
to me i didn't realize
all my [ __ ] childhood sadness was
gonna come
but i feel better i do feel better but
i'm not gonna be one of those douches
who took [ __ ] mushrooms and now
thinks that i understand the universe
ugh is there anything worse than when
somebody dumb takes mushrooms and then
they try to talk to you afterwards like
whatever they now they're like some like
they're deeper
it's like no i can just say it's like
dude you were tripping you were tripping
relax relax stop talking about the
vibrations
and how we're all part of it all right
you don't know what you're talking about
okay
you ate some [ __ ] that made you your
[ __ ] brain do some somersaults
that you're now mistaking as thinking
you weren't thinking you all right
whatever let people have that fun
so i've been doing um
i've been doing uh you know trying to
eat better so
i wanted to do a couple of uh these
vegetarian bowls just
you know not because i give a [ __ ] about
animals i do give a [ __ ] about animals
but i still want to eat them too at the
same time does that make any sense
it's probably a uh you know abusive
relationship but
um i'm just doing it for vanity purposes
i just
i don't have time to [ __ ] you know
there's no [ __ ] gym to go to right so
i was looking up plant-based
um dinners so buddha bulls comes up
like what the [ __ ] is a bootable so i
look it up and it's basically
this kind of amazing combination of all
these different foods with different
types of proteins and that type of [ __ ]
right
none of them meat-based right and i'm
sitting there making it and i'm like
you know with all the overly sensitive
[ __ ] people out there
how come bootables you know isn't buddha
like
somebody else's jesus like saying hey
you know you want some protein have some
jesus jerky
you have some mohammed marshmallows
right like you wouldn't go you wouldn't
you would never do you wouldn't do that
with jesus you wouldn't do it with
muhammad
what is it about buddha
that buddha does not get respected is
that because he's like
so [ __ ] chill
you know as chill as jesus was he still
got a hook
so i mean there was definitely you know
he had an absentee father
right his dad wasn't around
oh my god i never thought about that
you know i if god is real
right and i [ __ ] you know when i die
or whatever and i'm gonna get
judged i'm gonna be like all right you
got me on that one yeah that's another
good i knew you're gonna bring that up
let me ask you this hey least i was
there to play catch with my
kids where the [ __ ] were you oh
i worked for six days and then what'd
you do you put your feet up
you [ __ ] knocked up somebody's wife
[ __ ] you would [ __ ] judge me
of course i won't say that but you know
it's [ __ ] none of it
none of it makes [ __ ] sense right
none of it [ __ ] makes sense you know
what it is
life is about just trying not to be an
[ __ ] to other people
and if you have kids you just [ __ ]
hang out with them
until they're sick of you and then when
they're sick of you you give them their
space
and you just hope that during those
years when they looked at you like you
were their universe
that you gave them enough to navigate
all the [ __ ] [ __ ] that they're
gonna meet who had parents
who didn't play with them you know
you know what's cool i added to my
daughter's playlist i'm slowly just
adding to the playlist
um
i got her she's now listening to joan
jett you know which i think is really
important
when you have a daughter you gotta you
gotta show her women doing [ __ ]
so she doesn't become one of those women
women who just sits there and watches
guys do [ __ ]
you know one of those chicks more
worried about her nails than [ __ ]
achieving something not saying you have
to [ __ ] achieve [ __ ] but i'm just
saying
it's you know you open the door to say
hey you know you could [ __ ] do this
too right
like i saw there's somebody sent me this
[ __ ] video there's these balloons on
the wall
and this woman just [ __ ] i don't know
i'm not into martial i mean i
respect martial arts but i don't know
what the kicks are called she [ __ ]
just goes bang bang bang bang and then
there's one like
up where your [ __ ] head would be and
then she [ __ ] kicked that one
all while on one foot
and i showed that to my daughter just
[ __ ] like that
i just think it's important some you
know little girl playing drums
like doing [ __ ] you know i don't know
maybe i'm [ __ ] up but that's what i do
and then i try to teach him little
things
my daughter's getting really close to
being able to ride a bike man it's
[ __ ] amazing
it's [ __ ] amazing i'm only four years
old i you know i've never been more
wrong about something the goddamn
balance bike
it's genius um
so of course i tried to go to i took her
from a balance bike to the bike that i
bought her that had the pedals on
and now i'm realizing what i need to do
is take the pedals off
just let her balance on that and just
teach her the hand brakes next
and i remember that that's like all
about like the same way you learn how to
fly a helicopter they don't just don't
give you all
you know here's your feed is your
[ __ ] right hand and left hand go
ahead good luck they don't do that they
it's one you know control
at a time just do the collective they
let you do that for a little while you
get used to that okay now you're just
gonna do the pedals you do that
okay now i'll do the pedals and you you
do the cyclic and the collective and
then you just and then one day you're
doing the whole thing
and you're not even thinking about it so
i kind of got to go like
that way with it but uh she is a friggin
speed demon
and is not afraid it's almost scares me
how
like little fear she has
um and she's fallen a few times and she
still just [ __ ]
gets after it man it's it's i'm really
proud of her but like
i'm also scared to death so it's really
[ __ ] with my back
when she gets on the the real bike to
make sure she doesn't fall down i
gotta like bend down just at that
perfect angle
where it's you just your lower back's
like oh we're gonna be talking to you
tomorrow
morning yes we will be um
all right but anyways getting back to
the buddha bowls
uh whatever the veggie bowls i'll call
them uh just in case
you know in eight minutes this becomes a
thing you can't say anymore and then
somebody posts this [ __ ] thing
and then you know people start running
their [ __ ] yaps
whatever the [ __ ] they're gonna do who
gives a [ __ ]
um anyway let me do some uh
advertising here but i'm gonna i'm gonna
start if anybody knows like some good
recipes and [ __ ] like i actually
stumbled upon a website
that says click here to go directly to
the recipe
which is incredibly
incredibly [ __ ] considerate um
because i just don't want to sit through
your whole childhood story i just don't
want to do that
so um of course i can't find where that
[ __ ] website is but if you guys have
any any good ideas for that
um you know because here's the deal i'm
never going to go veggie like i mean i
can't lay off a steak i mean i [ __ ]
love a steak i love a pork chop
you know i kind of like it all
right but i also know that i need to
like some big study just came out
showing if you eat all these vegetables
and stuff like how
how much better it is for you and i'm a
[ __ ] old dad so i have to do it
um so if you guys have any good recipes
on some [ __ ] like that let me know
um all right let's do a uh
let's do a read here but for some reason
i don't have the name of the read
the name of the advertiser is that what
i'm trying to say
what the [ __ ] is it oh here we go stitch
fix
you know people online shopping can be
daunting
you know what for the first time in my
life i want to look up that word
is that intimidating you know those
[ __ ] words people just they use in a
sentence so you kind of know what it
means
and then every once in a while you'll
try it out and then you're kind of
looking at people like did i
did i use it right seemingly difficult
to deal with
and anticipate intimidating all right i
got it beautiful
daunting online shopping can be daunting
you never know if things will fit
returns are difficult
and you don't even know what store to
start with
this season let stitch fix do all the
work
as the d i like how they just just
really just sort of beat you down didn't
they
hey let's be on stitch fits hey let's be
honest you know what the [ __ ] you're
doing
you're intimidated hey hey sweetheart
let us handle it as the days get longer
and the weather gets colder it may be
time to take well
this coffee doesn't have to change soon
i mean this isn't daylight savings
coming up i thought daylight savings
used to be in april
where they switched it back anyway it
may be time to take a look
at your winter wardrobe if you want to
make a change
uh this season stitch fix can help you
choose new places you'll love
if your go-to outfit in 2020 has become
sweatshirts
20 20. if your go-to outfit was
in 2020 uh sweatshirts or yoga pants you
may be feeling like you're in a style
rut
let stitch fix help you feel excited
about what you're wearing
did you just look over your current cold
weather wardrobe options and get a chill
it's time to ditch that old sweater and
upgrade that jacket a stitch fix
personal stylist can help you
pick new pieces that are timeless stitch
fix
offers clothing hand selected by expert
stylist for your unique size
style and budget every piece is chosen
for your fit
and your life and it's easy it's an easy
solution to finding what makes you look
and feel your best
oh man i remember this is why you need
stitch fix i remember one time
i made some money in this business
finally and i was freezing my ass off
and i had enough money and i'm gonna go
out and go buy a new winter coat so i
went to [ __ ] macy's
and there was this coat right had it you
know the classic winter coat had that
bright orange
um on the inside and on the outside it
was light brown and i thought it looked
pretty sharp right and i bought this
[ __ ] thing
i don't think i ever got so much [ __ ]
and it was brand new so i couldn't throw
it out
i remember this this this woman that i
like just looked at me she's like damn
bill that is an
ugly ass coat i'm like
really i just bought it
you know and i was like i got to keep
this thing for [ __ ] at least three
winners
you know i don't have money to just keep
buying all these [ __ ] cars you know
what i wish back then there was a stitch
fix
you get to try on pieces at home before
you buy keep your favorites and send
back the rest
stitch fix has free shipping free
shipping easy returns and exchanges and
a prepaid return
envelope is included you just try this
[ __ ] on whatever you like you keep
whatever you do
you throw it back in the envelope and it
goes right to them it's done it's done
there's no subscription required that's
great
try stitch fix once or set up automatic
deliveries
you'll pay just 20 styling fee for each
box
which gets credited toward pieces you
keep and there's no hidden fees ever
stitch fix why am i so tired stitch fix
has styles and clothing to
you know why bill cause you're not
eating any meat man uh stitch fix has
styles and clothing to fit any occasions
for women
men and kids uh they ship all over the
u.s
and avail and are available in uk as
well get started today at stitchfix.com
mmp and you'll get 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com mmp for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
mmp so that's what you do dude keep
everything in it and what you don't like
[ __ ] sell it online
was i not supposed to say that well i
did oh this guy's dangerous
what's he gonna say next you ever heard
a guy
so sleepy yet still so dangerous that's
my new character
he had a buddha bowl and he's getting
sleepy
um anyway
uh what else what the [ __ ] else do i
want to talk about
um yes i will say this though with that
that little
[ __ ] excursion i did out there in the
desert that was definitely
a uh i don't know that was definitely
it was a good thing as much as it like
bummed me out
like as i was coming down i was even
thinking of my kids and i was still
feeling like
uh that profound loneliness
and not being loved so i was like i was
able to be like all right well i know
that's [ __ ]
so this has to be some oh this is how i
felt growing up
um i get it now i
get it
yeah i felt like a freak you know what i
mean
paul mccartney and stevie wonder talking
about [ __ ]
you know ebony and
ivory right i'm just sitting there go
what if you're orange
what happens if you're orange do i get
to live in harmony
um whatever uh
it was definitely interesting so uh
tonight
two times i got offered desserts and i
said i can't eat that stuff
i'm [ __ ] locked in it's hilarious my
daughter had this little peppermint
um i don't know where she got it it
looked like it wasn't like a junior man
i don't look like a little [ __ ]
it was like the size of a quarter and
she knew after she was done eating that
that she had to go to bed and she was
taking the tiniest
[ __ ] bites out of it and i was going
you have to finish that to go to bed i
know what you're doing and
she's just sitting there laughing at me
she goes no
dad i'm gonna eat it up and then she
would take a tiny bite and then just
start
cracking up laughing she has such an
amazing
amazing sense of humor and uh yeah so i
got her into joan jett now
and we pulled up to the school
and uh that's uh you know what part she
likes
because i sort of acted it out now she
likes doing it he was with me
yeah me and i point with my thumb point
back at myself and she likes doing that
now
so she i got her into the song and now
when i pulled up
to the school the song just came on and
she was like dad i want to stay in the
car
until this song's over and i was just so
awesome because i used to always do that
you know some song that i [ __ ] loved
was on and i was just like i don't give
a [ __ ] i'm gonna be late for work i need
to stay in the car
listen to this song and fantasize that
i'm in the band
you know so i can feel good about myself
so i can go in and do this [ __ ] job i
hate for the next eight hours right
so um i don't know it's cool then my
wife has a completely different
taste in music so when she rides with
her so i think she's going to get a nice
you know nice mix of music there
we shall see we shall see um
all right oh hey um my drum teacher dave
elich gave me a really cool
uh like drum lick
to work on all right for all you
drummers out there
it's right left both accented it's a
paradiddle diddle right right left right
right left left
and then kick kick and then you can
start it any way you want just like a
paradiddle you can start on whatever
note you want and just
you know on one you can do whatever
wherever you want to start it and it's
[ __ ] fun as [ __ ]
and if you're just playing singles and
doubles you know with some accents and
stuff and then you throw that lick in
like two times in a row and come back
you actually sound like you know what
the [ __ ] you're doing
um so give that a try all right that's
it that is the podcast
um please enjoy the music picked out by
the
always wonderful uh
andrew themless and then we'll have a
bonus half hour of
of uh thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast that
happened uh
i don't know a couple years ago that is
it all right everybody is joe biden
still president
it feels weird to have a [ __ ]
president where it's this quiet after
[ __ ] four years of people's
pulling their goddamn hair out like i
love the guy he's [ __ ] jesus he came
back oh my god or like
he's like the worst [ __ ] thing i've
ever seen
everything's just sort of like yeah yeah
it's kind of funny the president's name
is joe
just like the classic regular name yeah
joe six-pack joe blow joe biden
joe biden um we'll see how he does i
root for everybody i root for the home
team
i'm an american i root for him all right
that's it go [ __ ] yourselves have a
great weekend you [ __ ] and i'll talk to
you monday
hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's the monday morning podcast for
monday
uh march 4th 2013. how you doing how's
it going you like this
is it up early i hope it is because i'm
recording it uh on sunday night right
after watching the bruins lose to the
canadians let's get that out of the way
congratulations canadians you guys
canadian fans you guys deserve to win
the game
[ __ ] bruins jesus christ
you had the game and you blew it
oh my god they played like just [ __ ]
morons
they played like they just [ __ ]
played right into the canadians hands we
were up three to two for all you don't
watch
uh um watch hockey we were up three to
two and even though it was three to two
we were carrying the play and we we had
commanded the game
and then uh the canadians started
getting chippy we fell right into it
fell right i got a good idea chara take
a [ __ ] gay misconduct there you go
that'll help the effort i gotta admit
with nine minutes left i shut it off
once it was four to three i just shut
the [ __ ] thing off i was like
it's it's you gotta understand with the
bruins
when chara is not on the ice it's like
we pulled half our goaltender that's how
important he is he plays half the
[ __ ] game
that was just the worst some [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] player cross checks
sagan at the ice all right
whatever you know
you don't like to see it but
you [ __ ] go you got you take your can
they take the helmet off what if they
take the helmet off and then they start
throwing punches at that point do you
still get the gay misconduct
i just don't understand how
i just don't understand why you would do
that why would you you just basically
gave them a 20 minute power play
in the [ __ ] third period for the
simple fact that one of the best
defensemen in the league and the best
guy we have and all the ice he eats up
he's not even going to be out there
um very stupid very stupid the canadians
are much better team than they were last
year was a great game the canadians
didn't play the trap so it was [ __ ]
awesome hockey
and i was surprised with the amount of
[ __ ] canadian fans giving me [ __ ] on
twitter who don't even know what the
[ __ ] trap is i thought you guys came
out of the womb
with skates on
you know go on youtube they'll show you
what the [ __ ] it is
you sh those i don't know why they
stopped playing in play when they played
the penguins either
that was seven to six it was a [ __ ]
awesome game
up and down the ice they went
that's what i like you know you know
what's the one sports fan that i can't
stand
is the [ __ ] person who complains
about some [ __ ] and then when his team
does it he goes what i don't give a [ __ ]
you know that's like what the canadian
fans are doing with the [ __ ] trap
like they weren't crying was he
with boredom when they watched the
devils trap their way to
[ __ ] three cups were those not the mo
other than uh stevens was a great player
to watch but other than i know a lot of
people think he's dirty or whatever but
i i love that guy but other than that i
mean jesus christ
i mean it was like i mean it was almost
the end it was literally almost the end
of the sport
you know the whole [ __ ] game one team
would skate to about
mid ice they'd dump the puck in and the
goaltender could skate over the corner
they're trying to wrap it around the
boards the goalie could come over and
stop it in the corner
and then the defense would bring it up
the [ __ ] ice oh my god god forbid the
other team was playing it too and then
they'd [ __ ] try to you know dump and
chase they called it
it it was it was almost the end of the
league and
[ __ ] nhl for some reason nba is smart
enough to be like
all right guys are too big they're too
fast
at the end of the day this sport is
supposed to entertain fans
and i don't watch enough hoop but i know
that there's illegal defenses in hoop
for the [ __ ] life of me i don't
understand why the nhl just goes
hey listen guys stop playing that [ __ ]
all right just [ __ ]
play the way they used to play you know
let's let's
have some nice rushes and that type of
[ __ ] going up and down the ice a couple
of fights or whatever and let's get the
[ __ ] out of here
is that is that too hard is that too
hard are you really gonna [ __ ] get go
up one goal and then sit back on your
own [ __ ] blue line away from the
other to make a mistake
um i don't know i don't [ __ ] know but
i'm
really really disappointed in the bruins
for playing just right into their
[ __ ] hands sitting there
like an old man screaming at the tv no
no
don't do that escape back to the bench
what are you doing why would you do that
ah i think last time i saw chara fight i
think i believe
last time i watched it was in buffalo
and he was just in the box for five
[ __ ] minutes and we immediately
became like a like
you know we look like a a 500 team
um it's not as bad now because we got we
got some other guys back there on
defense but jesus [ __ ] christ
so i gotta be honest with you i don't
know what to to take away from that game
because i can't really say that we saw
the canadians because uh price wasn't in
that
and uh you know and then chara takes
that stupid [ __ ] penalty so he didn't
play a third of the game
i don't know i still think we're a
better team so i feel good and i look at
montreal they look like uh
a second round of the playoffs gonna get
bounced out which will make me happy
then that'll be 22 seasons 21 years
without a cup
and just with every year they look more
and more like matthew mcconaughey and
dazed and confused
like it's [ __ ] over and they don't
realize it yet you know
i mean jesus [ __ ] christ
they still walk around arrogantly
canadian fans do
like living off of like you know what
they're like at this point
they're like trust fund kids
[Laughter]
you know like their grandfather made all
the money and now they're riding around
this maserati that like
interest paid for and they're they're
looking at you like there's some sort of
success and you're looking like dude you
haven't done [ __ ]
you haven't done [ __ ] in your life what
are you puffing your chest out for
you know wearing your high school jacket
with all your grandfather's
accomplishments written up and down the
[ __ ] sleeves
do you remember that championship they
won back in 1958 you don't you [ __ ]
seriously you know i'll i'll take [ __ ]
from canadian fans that are like my age
because i know that they remember the uh
the patrick wah
championships but these punks in their
20s right up to their early 30s you guys
can all go [ __ ] yourselves because i
know you don't remember anything
even last time the canadians won it you
were upstairs and you lit jam jams
you know getting ready to have some
dreams so go [ __ ] yourselves
all right with your most overrated run
of championships oh let's start an
argument here
i'll ask you guys this what do you think
and i already congratulated the
canadians for winning right did i do
that so i'm not being a total [ __ ] here
i just love [ __ ] on them um what do
you think is the most
overrated overrated collection of like
you know championships uh the celtics
the boston celtics the 11 that they won
in the 1960s
the new york yankees or the montreal
canadiens
i would i would put them in this order i
would say canadians top of the list
then i would say celtics and then i
would say yankees
you know and this this is why okay the
canadians dominated a six-team league
and they had first
choice of every french-born canadian
player for like the first
[ __ ] 50 years it's like they had
their own lottery draft
every [ __ ] year all right and not to
mention there's five other teams i mean
give me a [ __ ] really you went on a
run
holy [ __ ] how did you do that you know
then i would say i i would say
the only reason why i'm putting the
celtics next is because
the yankees basically had jordan
they there was such a good front office
that they grabbed the jordan
three generations in a row you know
i mean we gave them [ __ ] babe ruth
like [ __ ]
because we wanted to have a musical i
think people
should sing too right so we give them
babe ruth but they had lou gehrig
they went from lou gehrig babe ruth of
lou gehrig
to [ __ ] joe dimaggio to mickey mantle
um i don't i'm good i don't think you're
ever gonna see that again
that would be like if one team drafted
uh you went doctor the sixers got dr j
and then they [ __ ] drafted michael
jordan and then they drafted like kobe
bryant or lebron
like within like what is that like 30
years within 30 years
from the 1920s and 1950s they had that
so i put the celtics second
because um
i know i guess it was a newer league
well the league started in the 40s but
it was still the 1960s it was still it
was wilt chamberlain
but all those championships back then
though the amazing thing about it was
like the amazing argument it's like okay
well it's distilled down so there's
there's uh the talent level obviously
should have been higher i guess
but for some of you youngsters out there
like back in the day when you won the
pennant in baseball there were so few
teams
i should have done my research i used to
know this [ __ ] there was like literally
like maybe
seven teams in each um in each league
so it was basically winning the pennant
was having the best record at the end of
the regular season that was winning the
pennant and if you had the best record
in the american league you immediately
went to the world
series there was no wild card no
divisional series
and then the [ __ ] alcs you
immediately you went
to the world series so basically after
you won
all those games in the regular season
you had to win
four more um and i think that that's why
you saw teams go on
i don't know i think that that's why you
saw like a yankees a celtics or a a
canadian sting where they could go on
runs because
there was so there was way fewer teams
and you had
in even like the playoffs playoffs was
was so much shorter
like i was talking to my buddy lawhead
he said yeah the amount of times that
the
cleveland indians won over a hundred
games and they didn't even make the
playoffs
because the yankees had a couple more
wins um
and you know the playoffs go anybody can
[ __ ] win you have a bad day or a bad
couple of games next thing you know you
bounced out in the first [ __ ] round
100 wins go right down the toilet that
didn't happen back then so
uh i would be interested to hear but i
mean i i think obviously just the sheer
number of teams
and then that unbelievably ridiculous
advantage that the canadians had that
they had first
choice of every french-born canadian
player
you know i mean what the [ __ ] um
but anyways anyways going and i i
promise you this if the bruins ever
start playing the trap i will
immediately stop watching them
um because i i i like the game of hockey
i don't like watching it being
suffocated
all right bill you've made your god damn
point how long did i talk about hockey
and this
i can guarantee you there's no women
left listening to this [ __ ] thing
11 minutes does it sound all right i'm
back to my old contraption here i bought
yet another memory card somebody on
twitter told me that the
lovely zoom h4 and recorder could only
take one that
had 32 gigabytes or some [ __ ] so i went
out and i bought one of those and i
stuck it in there and they said that
there was nothing in there so uh
i don't know if i had a fish tank that's
where this recorder would be at the
bottom of it because it kind of looks
like one of those castles that the
goldfish swing
swim in and out of um all right let's
get on with the podcast this is the
monday morning podcast everybody
um i'm actually in a great [ __ ] move
despite the fact
that my bruins lost um
i remember i was telling you how titus
showed me how to uh well basically did
the job and then just stood over my
shoulders i did the other one when
we converted my front brakes from drum
brakes to disc brakes
so i've had those drum brakes in my
garage saying that i was gonna put those
[ __ ] together
and uh and they just been sitting there
mocking me every time i'm walking by
like what's up [ __ ]
what's what's up [ __ ] what titus isn't
here to [ __ ] hold your hand your
little [ __ ] [ __ ]
every time i saw him they were bugging
me
so uh i went on i went on the internet
there
i went to amazon.com that's what i did
everybody right through the billboard
website in the podcast page i clicked on
it i actually got money kicked back to
me that i'm gonna kick onto the troops
and i bought the the kit um
you know to help you put the [ __ ]
springs on and all that [ __ ] so
underrated for this week
actually having the tools for the job
that you need because i watched all
these guys these weekend warriors going
like you know there's just
there's a special tool for this but if
you don't have it uh
you know needle nose pliers will work
get yourself a screwdriver and uh no
go out and get the [ __ ] things that
you need and uh
i actually got them all together i think
i [ __ ] up one of the springs i think
one of them
because when i got to the last spring
that was left
it didn't seem like it fit right so i'm
going to bring it down to uh
the guy who works on my truck normally
and i have him show me how to [ __ ] do
it but i was psyched i probably i'll put
a picture up of what i what i have done
so far i got it basically three quarters
done
and i have some extra parts some clips
and a couple of screws
so i'm like 80 percent there and um
i don't know i think i breathed in a
bunch of asbestos too
i didn't realize actually i did and i
was like
i'm outside i'm fine and then i've got
this word i already had a scratchy
feeling in my throat i thought i was
catching a cold but now it feels like
an asbestos-y kind of cold um
but anyways man i'm i'm psyched i'm
gonna get these [ __ ] things together
because remember that carburetor i told
you i took apart
i tried and i was gonna rebuild it i
went nuts i took the whole [ __ ] thing
apart right down to those
those little flat it was a four barrel
right down those little flapper things
i don't know what you call them but i
took them out and now they won't fit
back in because i think all the years of
it just being so hot they're a little
warped
i can't get them back in so if anybody
knows where i can buy those parts
i don't mean like a re rebuilt kit i
have all that [ __ ]
i need the actual parts to the
carburetor and
it's making me sick every time i look at
it um
because that's literally the first thing
i have to put back together and i i
can't get them
i can't get them to fit um so if anybody
knows where i can order that [ __ ] i'd
appreciate it all right all right what
the [ __ ] am i talking about this week
um you know i went to go look at a uh a
story on the internet that i somehow
missed
because i've been traveling so much and
one of the advertising
the advertising before like the little
youtube video
was uh oh before i forget i i gotta i'm
gonna post the uh the youtube video
of this southern dude who was doing the
drum breaks on his buddy's mustang
that actually taught me how to do it the
guy's a [ __ ] riot
he knows what he's doing but he's
drinking the whole time and every time
he takes a sip he goes cheers
and it was he just he filmed it in real
time so he [ __ ] up
you know a couple of times had to take
some [ __ ] off he just put some [ __ ] on
too soon or whatever and then you know
kind of had to go back and forth but
just
watching a guy he just left the camera
on it was really great so if you're
ever thinking of doing it if a dumb ass
like me can figure it out
sort of you know i'm not gonna lie to
you i had some extra parts
[Laughter]
[Music]
but after tomorrow when i go down the
garage the guy's going to show me what i
did wrong and i'm going to have it down
i'll do the other one and i know how to
do it
so i'll definitely post that video and
um so anyways
um this advertising comes on right
before this news story that i somehow
missed
and um it shows this guy
out on a lake on a jet ski or something
like that and these two ladies
are sitting on the bench on the beach i
mean and they go
uh she goes so when one of the ladies
says to the woman who's married to the
guy in the jet ski so does he still keep
it in the driveway and she's like
not anymore you know like now that it's
like in storage
was basically an advertising
advertisement for storage
right so of course you know
these storage companies that they're
basically advertising the [ __ ] ladies
out there
because what what what do women do the
second you get married to them
you know they take over the [ __ ]
house and all your [ __ ] ends up out in
the garage
and if there's anything that sits in the
driveway how long before they want you
to sell it
you know what i mean did they give a
[ __ ] that it's the last
[ __ ] flame flickering in your heart
you know something you have a passion
for an old car you want to fix up a
[ __ ] jet ski
right and this [ __ ] woman is sitting
there gloating
this guy's out on the lake having the
[ __ ] time of his life from this
goddamn jet ski
she sees how much she enjoys it does she
give a [ __ ] no it's a [ __ ]
eyesore to her i really don't understand
how women have like that motherly thing
where they're like these absolute angels
and at the same [ __ ] time
they're they're like these i don't know
what they are
what is the [ __ ] word it's not like a
leech they're like these uh
i don't know what is that old thing
where a cat a cat sleeps on your
chest it steals your life breath or
something like that or is that when you
hold the milk in front of your mouth and
a [ __ ] tapeworm comes out i can't
there's something
there's something somewhere in there
yeah somewhere there
there's a reference that would have been
funny three minutes ago sorry
um i just don't understand it
that's why nia's the [ __ ] he doesn't
give a [ __ ] i got my drum stuff my
guitar stuff she knows i'm a big kid
and she lets me have it she's never said
oh why don't you take your [ __ ] and put
it in storage
you know but all these [ __ ] women
they show in these
advertisings and all these [ __ ]
sitcoms and [ __ ]
i don't know i just don't understand it
why why you know at the end of the day
you know whose fault it is
it's the [ __ ] guy in the jet ski
you know when she's sitting there
breaking his [ __ ] balls
there's there's there's there's a great
line that you can use
when you're just sick of your woman
she's just crossed
too many lines and she's on a [ __ ]
roll and she's going and
thing here you got that jet ski out
there my mother's coming to town
and taking up all that space we need
room for a car but she's on a [ __ ]
roll
there's a great simple thing that you
can say to them
you know to make them stop it's
basically this all right all right all
right
that's what you do and then you sit in
the awkward silence
so you're yelling at me now yeah i am
why are you doing that because you're
[ __ ] annoying me don't curse with me
i'm not cursing at you
i'm cursing cause i'm angry it's my
[ __ ] jet ski i enjoy it
i like going out in the the [ __ ] lake
doing a little loopty loose
a little dosey doe whatever whatever the
[ __ ] slang is on jet skis
i like doing it okay and i don't have to
haul my ass all the way down to the
[ __ ] storage shed on the other side
of town
every time i feel like taking a lap
around the lake why don't we put some of
your [ __ ] shoes down there
how about that some no no
shut up stop well you're talking when
i'm talking
didn't that that's why that [ __ ] word
exists you shut your face lady
all right my jet ski goes down to the
[ __ ]
uh storage center so does some of your
uh sort of some of your shoes
[ __ ] only my jet ski only my [ __ ]
goes down there what kind of [ __ ]
lopsided trade is this
like i'm dismantling the team of my life
go [ __ ] yourself you got to give
somebody else too
give somebody else up there we go
see that that's why you know i don't
know if this that this kind of shit's
going to cause me to live longer
or die earlier but literally that's what
a 14 second advertisement can [ __ ] do
to me
i get upset at this this hypothetical
[ __ ] relationship
and this guy who's on this just jet ski
and goes into a green screen
storage door
i don't know if there's any women who
still listen to this can you can you
please answer me like two things what do
you have against
the guy you're with having fun without
you and two
what is it that guys do what is the male
equivalent
to doing that because i know we balance
each other out at this point
okay but i'm a guy so i only see
you know i'm like a homer announcer i
only see the [ __ ] offenses
that are on my side you know uh that
affect me
but really just just the way they said
now hey [ __ ] he's going to crash the
street oh
[ __ ] you you should have just rev that
engine and just [ __ ] ran right over
nice propeller to the [ __ ] cleavage
that's disgusting
um anyways you know i think that's a
good time
that's a nice setup for some advertising
this week
oh geez 22 minutes in some i'll tell you
i'll tell you some weeks it's easy some
weeks it's hard
this seems like it's going to be an easy
one all right let's let's uh let's do
the thing here
oh christ where is it where have you
gone billy boy
billy boy all right here we go
all right um which one is this one
oh legalzoom.com everybody guess what
it's national biz national start your
business month i thought last month was
that
well you know what legalzoom's killing
it so hard every month should be
national legal zoom no national start
your business
month do i have dyslexia
um let's start over again once again
it's national start your business month
at legalzoom.com
okay i know i've been talking about this
for more than a month
but so many oh they already already had
it covered but so many of you are
starting businesses right now so
legalzoom has decided to extend it
through march
you like that's that's the kind of power
legal zoom has
okay they're like bloomberg you know the
terms up and they're still going
they're still in office that's that's
that's how much these guys are killing
it
i'll call it whatever you want just
remember this is a great time to start
your business
whether you're starting up an llc an s
corp sole proprietorship
or a non-profit legal zoom takes care of
you from start to finish
their award-winning service was
developed by the best legal minds in the
country
and every business gets personalized
attention that's why over ninety percent
of legalzoom customers would recommend
the service to their family
uh you'll be in good company three dozen
companies on the inc
500 list were started through legalzoom
start your business
right at legalzoom.com legalzoom is not
a law firm and provides self-help
self-help services at your specific
direction in other words if you're
having a problem call them up
and their law team will help you uh but
there's so much more now every llc and
incorporation package includes easy to
use business accounting software
a 269 dollar value for absolutely free
be sure to enter bur b-u-r-r and the
referral box to check out start your
business protect your family
and safeguard your assets at legalzoom
today
all right and of course the classic
the classic stamps.com everybody
stamps.com where the hell is it where is
it
where have you gone stamps.com where
have you gone
you've lasted a whole day long you know
as a kid the first record my mother got
me was sing along with mitch miller in
the gang did i ever tell you that
i've sung those before right i you know
led zeppelin was putting out albums at
that time aerosmith was just starting
out
ac dc david bowie
james brown who else was putting out
albums when i got that
it was insane i guess jimi hendrix
joplin and morrison had just died
jackson five and just all these amazing
artists and my mom comes home with
sing-along with mitch miller and the
gang
so everybody at school knew all these
cool songs that i'm walking around going
five foot two eyes of blue but oh what
those five foots could do has anybody
seen
[Applause]
now if you run into a five foot two
covered with pearls bum bum bum diamond
rings and all those things you bet your
life fit
isn't her but could she love could she
coo could she could she coochie coo has
anybody
seen my girl and my hair was orange
is it anything that's it any wonder
i ended up doing this [ __ ] talking to
myself in the basement of my [ __ ]
home
oh by the way i finally got the roof put
on my house
loving life that's one of those things
that you absolutely love and your girl
could give a [ __ ] about
i'm standing up there you know just
staring at it
talking to neil look at it look at the
[ __ ] top paper
right she could give a [ __ ] she's like
yeah you know it's nice
it's very nice it's going to keep it
like 15 degrees cooler
we used to have the black now it's a
white now it's white you know it's going
to reflect light rather than attracting
do you understand what's going on yeah
i think it's um that's tar paper
all right stamps.com everybody you know
it's funny everyone who fast forwarded
through the ads just missed me singing
that song
stamps.com everybody uh odds are you're
most productive when you're working from
your desk so leaving just to go to the
post office can slow you down
you can also get stuck in traffic you
can have a flat tire god knows somebody
could rear-end you
you know somebody could point it you
went to with police officers going
that's the guy that's the guy who did it
right then you got to get a lawyer
you know that's why you need stamps.com
with stamps.com you can buy
print buy and print official us postage
right from your own computer
and printer and nobody can accuse you
for for a crime you didn't commit
stance.com will send you a digital scale
automatically calculates the exact
postage you need for any letter or
package
any class of mail you'll never waste
valuable time going to the post office
again
do everything right from your
deskwithstamps.com print postage
you need put it on your letter or
package just hand it to your mail
carrier and you're done
i use stamps.com to send out all my dvds
i just did it this week
so easy even this [ __ ] can do it right
now use my last name bur b-u-r-r for a
special offer no risk trial plus 110
dollar bonus
offer includes digital scale and up to
five dollars free postage don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in bur bur
that stamps dot com enter bur and there
we go
there we go won't you come home bill
bailey won't you
come home that's what i would be singing
everybody else was singing you know like
sweet emotion and i'm walking around
going roll out the barrel
we'll have a barrel of fun we got it
bill you listen to a bad record
all right so anyways it was a news story
that i sudden
somehow missed out on um i've been
living a very uh
cavernous life recently um
i've been really busy so i i've missed
out on a lot of uh
a lot of stories how the [ __ ] did i miss
out on this and jim norton actually did
a bit about this
on the patrice o'neal benefit and i
missed it because i was i was in the
back somewhere making sure you know
freaking out making sure everybody had
food and all that i never arranged one
of those things before so
you know i was i was i was like that
[ __ ] nerd who had a party and was
worried that no one was going to show up
or they'd show up and say that it sucked
i guess he did a story on this it said a
man charged with slapping a toddler
on a minneapolis to atlanta flight is
out of a job
this guy got up and he slapped a baby
and the baby was african-american and he
dropped the n-word
i mean i've been trying to fig
like that's got to be like
as far as ending your career that's like
just
i mean i don't know how you could have
done it any better like if you truly
just wanted to get fired i mean you
could have stopped with slapping a baby
that is
i mean that is just i can't
can you [ __ ] you haven't been on a
plane the baby starts crying i
i always get blown away by people who
get annoyed by it
i always find it funny and relatable
like when i hear a baby start crying i
just think like
i just i'm i'm jealous of the freedom of
it because i want to do that too
like how great that would be just any
time you just life started to suck you
just
do that you know how oh my god it's
like verse paul verzi has a bit just i
gotta stop paul versus he has a [ __ ]
just like this
wait i gotta stop here go see paul verzi
for the rest of this [ __ ] ideas oh my
god
accidentally almost stumbled into that
one um
but i've always felt that though
can you [ __ ] believe going up
and slapping forget the whole racial
thing just standing up
i mean we've all had a couple of drinks
we've all said some things
you know how many [ __ ] drinks do you
have well
your brain goes why don't you go over
there and slap that baby in the [ __ ]
head
i could see if you were driving by and
there was a baby standing on the street
corner
and you took the plates off your car i
could see in your drunk mind
thinking that you were going to get away
with that but this guy if you did that
in the mall
it would be over this guy does it on a
plane there's nowhere to go there's no
way to go
you know you know what when they make
the sequel to like snakes on a plane
they sh this is what it should be it
should be sam
jackson as a baby and some racist white
guy
slaps him in the face and and calls him
the n-word and then that it just sets
him
and that guy's actually part of the
illuminati
i'm just throwing [ __ ] against the wall
that guy's part of the illuminati
and the reason why he's on a commercial
airline flight is uh
maybe he got a little too out of control
at the last secret meeting he didn't do
the handshake right you know
and as a punishment he actually had to
fly commercial like first
class and uh
and it's actually it's a baby sam
jackson
and and it's whatever snakes on a plane
snakes meaning like the illuminati like
they're pieces of [ __ ]
snakes on a plane part two and then the
the tag is
you just slap the wrong [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i'm sorry sometimes this shit's just
funny to me
but um oh and then he drops the n word i
mean jesus i mean this guy is just like
it's just as far as evil it would be
like i can't even imagine would be like
getting eaten by a snake and a shark at
the same time like it wouldn't be
possible
like the level of evil that is in that
man's heart
you know jesus i'm trying to like he's
sick he's a 60 year old guy from idaho
and i even think the 60 is too young at
this point
to still be dropping the n word you know
you get somebody at this point let's see
60 years old
you were well you know now you were born
in the 50s come on man
you're born to fit you should know
better all right
even white guy in the middle of nowhere
you should know better so i feel like
the
the the white person dropping the n-word
kind of [ __ ] even though i know there's
a bunch of hate groups out there i'm
just talking the average everyday joe
just on a [ __ ] plane
saying that type of [ __ ] that's like uh
you know at this point i think you you
were born in like the 20s
in the 30s maybe the 40s maybe bill
clinton was in the 40s right
he's playing saxophone on arsenio hall
how you doing even did the cool
handshake
right white people have come a long way
this guy
just set white people back the only
thing that say that he's an old white
guy and i think
people always just look at old people as
like they were born in the 1800s at
least i do
maybe that's me because i'm only 45 this
year and i just realized that i'm 15
years away from being 60 years old
and you know what i'm all right with
that you know
i mean salads i'm doing pull-ups go [ __ ]
yourself
all right i'm it's not like i'm aging
any quicker than anybody else
we all listen we all get a day older
every day
okay now the great thing about being my
age is if they [ __ ]
we get hit by an asteroid i got 45 years
in
all right you only got 20 something but
they're they're great 20 years your
first 20.
now they think of it you didn't have to
deal with a bunch of other [ __ ] did you
i don't know but let's this this has
kind of gone off the rails here
um so i apologize like i really missed
out on a bunch of stories i don't
i just kind of obviously as you can tell
from the first 11 minutes of this
podcast all i do is watch hockey
and then try and uh put together
auto parts while breathing in asbestos
um embattled scottish cardinal
o'brien cardinal o'brien apologizes for
my sexual conduct
you know i'm getting sick of people
apologizing for [ __ ] and they dance
around
this guy basically to use my new word he
buggered some kids
all right he took out his holy [ __ ] olio
and stuck it in there [ __ ] uh uh
uh what the [ __ ] was jesus born in a
shed
what do they always call it you know
always around christmas i remember what
it's called what was he was born in a
barn but they give it some biblical
what's the name for a biblical barn i
don't give a [ __ ] anyways it says a
scottish cardinal who had earlier
earlier
challenged allegations of his sexual
impropriety
claims that once again claims that once
again shined an
international spotlight on the alleged
alleged sexual abuse evolving
involving roman catholic clergy reverse
course sunday
and the guy apologized this is how he
apologizes
for basic i for as far as i can tell
[ __ ] children in the ass
he said i wish to take this opportunity
to admit
that there have been times that my
sexual conduct
has fallen below the standards expected
of me as a priest
archbishop and cardinal
in recent days certain allegations which
have been made against me have become
public
initially they're anonymous and
non-specific nature
led me to contest them to those i have
offended
i apologize and ask forgiveness
to those i've offended you know
i've been lucky enough in my life to
have never been unwantedly
[ __ ] banged in the ass by a [ __ ]
priest
but i don't i think i can be empathetic
enough
and say that if this was happening at no
point would i be turning around going
you know that's
what you're doing is really offensive i
find this you know what the [ __ ]
when you apologize you should have to
say what the [ __ ] you did
and if you're gonna talk like this there
should be somebody obnoxiously yelling
off the mic
like what you did like during this
apology should have been like
i wish to take this opportunity to admit
that there have been times
that my sexual conduct has fallen below
the standards expected of me as a priest
yeah and as a [ __ ] human being you're
not supposed to [ __ ] kids
in recent days certain allegations
[ __ ] of children which have been made
against me
have become public about [ __ ] time
initially their anonymous
and non-specific nature led me to
contest them
how many different ways do we got to
explain it
you took your [ __ ] dick you put in
their ass you got the point
um good lord to those i have offended to
those you raped
you're a [ __ ] rapist and like how
like
he tries to tie in the fact that he's a
priest
like below the standards expected of me
as a priest archbishop
archbishop and cardinal
so like
what if you were a pope that was okay
or was it because you never became a
pope so this guy's basically been
diddling kids ever since
he got into that [ __ ] how is that
thing still in business it's just
[ __ ] beyond me
um anyways so that's the news for this
week everybody i hope you enjoyed it
um let's get on with some sort of uh
uh what do we got here did i talk about
everything i wanted to talk about
yeah i think i did all right cool all
right new girl hey bill
love your comedy and just wanted to ask
a clarifying question
my guy always gives me crap for watching
the show new girl
uh due to the fact that he thinks the
show
is ridiculous he refuses to believe
that you did a spot on it can you please
verify whether or not you were on a show
as nick's cousin
i know you're a busy guy but i listen to
your podcast
and know that you respond personally to
emails which is great
um i can either confirm nor deny that
that is top secret information and i'm
not allowed to talk about it
um but chances are good yeah i did an
episode of that i did an episode of it
uh two weeks ago
um does that help you win your argument
will that make your boyfriend like the
show more i doubt it
uh he thinks the show's ridiculous so he
refuses to believe that i did a spot on
it well tell him this i did a spot on it
and everybody in the show was [ __ ]
hilarious
and i had a great time and i also got to
work with nick kroll
who had me die and laughing between
every take i was laughing like a school
girl so i had a great time on the show
it's unfortunate your boyfriend can't
enjoy the show but
you know what that's why there's other
shows um
but i actually liked how your your
boyfriend views me
that i am big enough to actually turn
down acting work
have him one day sit down and read my
imdb page and eight seconds later when
he's finished
[Laughter]
i would do a pilot of a show that was
ripping off sesame street
and i would play the lower half of big
bird at this point i don't give a [ __ ]
um so if i get to be on a hit show like
that yeah
i absolutely i had a great time i had a
great time on that show
and uh you know just tell your boyfriend
he doesn't have to watch it
all right hey bill i'll keep this short
but my wife of three years cheated on me
back in july
oh jesus well she did it three years in
please don't have any kids please don't
have any kids please don't have any kids
after telling her that i wanted to work
things out
she [ __ ] left me for another dude in
november not even a dude she cheated on
me with
ah man yeah that's one of those deals
where you still loved her
and she just [ __ ] hit you with a
giant bucket of water and you were in
shock
um so you tried to work it out with that
cheating [ __ ]
uh anyways he said i was friends with
this girl since high school
as was her wait a minute i was friends
with this girl since high school
as was with her oh and was with her you
wrote as and was with her for a total of
six years
and she broke broke off our marriage via
text
what a [ __ ] [ __ ] anyways i'm 30 years
old
in great shape live on my own have been
on a dating website for a couple months
and i've yet to go out on a date with
anyone because i secretly think all
these girls
just like getting guys to look at their
online profiles but never want to go out
on a date
my question is should i continue to try
and find someone through online dating
or somewhere else
i've only been with two girls my entire
life i want to take your advice and get
it out of my system for a bit
before i settle down with someone else
yeah dude why don't you
first of all you're only 30 years old
which is really young nowadays
why don't you give yourself a little bit
of time to heal from what the hell you
just went through
before you jump into something else
learn a little bit about yourself
figure out what you're looking for and
what you what you want
what's a deal breaker what what is
something that you want you know you're
looking for and then i would go into a
relationship like that
um i online dating i think is great i
mean
if i was a young guy i would do that in
a second i mean that's just like
all of a sudden you become like the bill
belichick a [ __ ]
you know it's like you got your own
draft
you look it's it's like you're looking
at the the [ __ ] the nfl
combine you know but instead of seeing
their vertical leap
you're looking at like their titties i
don't know what you're doing the thing
but
um look it could have been a lot worse
she could have done it like when you
were 40 and you already had a couple of
kids then you'd have to pay for a
cheating ass too
um i think the fact that you guys were
young when you got married i don't think
she knows how to break up with somebody
she probably deliberately sabotaged the
relationship and the fact that she sent
a text
she doesn't like confrontation she's
still very immature
um so what are you gonna do but whatever
she's in the rearview mirror i would
you know the best revenge is living a
great life
so take some time go travel
go [ __ ] i don't know do something
learn how to fly a helicopter or ride a
motorcycle go to europe
you know go go to a super bowl blow some
cash just
do something for yourself figure out
what you want to do
and i just tell women you're not ready
to get into something until you are
that's it and be totally 100 honest how
can you call me back i thought you had a
good time
i had a great time but i didn't feel
that feeling like you were the one i'm
sorry
you know bing bang boom real [ __ ]
quick
and uh you know the second you're honest
like that that's when you'll eventually
find the person you're supposed to be
with when you keep lying to people
because you don't hurt their feelings
you just end up hurting yourself so
sorry you went through that
um but uh you know what dude it's your
it's your time right now so enjoy
yourself
all right dearest bill ex-girlfriend
won't x what does that mean won't exit
i need some advice on how to handle a
crazed woman
oh jesus i don't know dude this is rough
a crazed woman uh i'm 18 and have joined
the marine corps
and i leave for basic in a few months
well jesus is a great out
there's a way to get out of a
relationship you know i'd love to keep
seeing you but i
i joined the marines yeah sorry about
that
i know it's crazy all right see you
anyways he said i've been dating this
girl for about six months and dumped her
because
i feel like the last thing i need when
i'm away is a relationship with someone
who i will never see exactly the girl
has constantly been blowing up my phone
for the past couple of weeks
i thought she would calm down over time
but it seems to be getting worse
i started to get really concerned when i
arrived home the other day
and she was at my house talking to my
mother who thinks this girl is the
greatest thing that ever happened to me
how can i get this girl out of my life
any advice
uh would be greatly appreciated love the
podcast go [ __ ] yourself
um all right well what this i get
already like you just don't answer any
of her calls
all right and you know if she shows up
where you're at just say
leave me alone i don't want to talk and
just you know eventually
i mean you can't get blood from a stone
and i would immediately talk to your
mother and just and say listen i know
you love this girl but uh i don't
this isn't going to be the mother of my
kids and she's stalking me
okay so i need you to not talk to her
and then that's it start with that and
then after that
um i don't know where you go after that
stun gun
i don't know dude you're going to the
marine soon so it's going to be [ __ ]
over
when did you say leave for basic in a
few months yes tell your mother to stop
talking to her
just say she's [ __ ] nuts and uh
yeah that shouldn't be that hard i mean
she she's just blowing up your phone
you know she's not peeing in the batter
of the brownies that you then eat with
your [ __ ] best friend right like last
week
um anyways new pope a boston billy love
the podcast keep up the good work thank
you
what do you make of all this news about
the pope retiring
oh geez personally i'm not that
religious and don't really care that
much maybe if they elected a new pope
that was young
well that was a young some young hot
lady
in her 20s i would give a [ __ ] what do
you think bill is there more to the
story that that they're not telling us
were his age and health issues the only
reason he retired
is the church covering anything up uh
well come on dude are they covering
anything up they they
[ __ ] have been a certain
percentage of them have been covering up
other
[ __ ] kids for a long time
you know during world war ii there was
uh you know they got in bed with the
nazis
i mean it really is one of the worst
organizations as far as some of the [ __ ]
that they've done
you know but people are so wrapped into
not pissing off the invisible guy and
wanting to go to the happy place and get
to eat marshmallows for the rest of your
fall [ __ ] eternity that they are
actually
it's really it's it's disturbing
that people can still be part of that
religion
you know what i mean i don't understand
how you know the stuff that they've done
so uh yeah
i would say yeah there's probably
something going on
i don't know maybe he said something
like uh hey you know uh
maybe we should apologize for uh
having that clambake with adolf hitler
should we uh maybe
clear the air with that one hey what do
you say
uh we actually don't help to pay for the
lawyers of
the people in our organization who put
their dicks in the asses of kids
you know maybe he said something like
that i have no idea
anyways he said also what are some some
of the ways that they could make the
church more interesting for example
maybe let broads become priests
i bet more people would pay attention or
how about letting people sit in lazy
boys instead of sitting and kneeling in
those terrible rock hard benches they
call
pews i know it's so dumb the whole thing
is to get you
like you're not worthy you're not worthy
you're not worthy
get on your [ __ ] knees and it's and
it's all
it's all made up by human beings
taking a guess and and other adults
because they get into it as kids they
they
i don't know why i actually know why
because i i believe that there is like
a spirituality and i believe that you
feel good when you do good things and i
just think that
you can't corral that nobody owns it you
can't put a [ __ ]
like i think that all churches should
just be philosophies
rather than this this hardened way of
looking at things
um just the amount of death that it has
caused
i don't i'm not saying anything [ __ ]
new you guys know how i feel on this
[ __ ]
um finally how about we liven up the
music a bit and add some newer sounds
maybe a little guitar and drums well
what you need to do is go to a baptist
church
go to a church where you don't see any
white people going in there
um that would be a good one to start
with
and i i bet you're amazing you'll you'll
hear people who actually in those
churches probably sing
better than half the people who won
grammys that year i mean how many times
you've seen some emaciated [ __ ]
sticking her finger in the ear trying to
act like they know how to sing and what
are they what's behind them all the
[ __ ] time
it's always like [ __ ] three black
chicks or two black
chicks and some black dude i mean that's
where the music is that's where it's
coming from if that's what you want just
[ __ ] go there
they're not gonna give a [ __ ] right they
may look at you weird but after a while
once they see you feeling the music you
should be fine
you should be fine the rest of the [ __ ]
i don't know i think that they should
maybe update the uh
stories every once in a while
maybe uh just make up some new [ __ ] just
say oh you know what
god came back again and the burning bush
said uh
you know let he who never uh
illegally downloaded the song just
something to [ __ ] update it i don't
know what to tell you
you know what i mean i don't know
updated i guess you know there are some
sort of some of those new age
the new age ones are just too scary
because then somehow somebody always
ends up saying they're jesus and the
next thing you know you're surrounded by
the fbi
and there's tanks shooting flames at you
or you're waiting for some aliens to
come
and next thing you know everybody's
drinking some poison and you die in a
[ __ ] bunk bed
you know or in the middle of the jungle
with some
sweaty [ __ ] conga player whatever the
[ __ ] that guy's name was
you know i think you better is when it
comes to uh spirituality and that type
of [ __ ] i think you're really you're
better off on your own
um i think
you know i think generally speaking if
you're not a psycho you kind of know how
to be a decent human being i'm not
saying that you always succeed in it
i certainly don't but um
how the [ __ ] do i put it i would rather
sit at a bar
about six seven beers in and talk to
somebody else who is in the same mind
frame
and talk about life than i would to
actually go to a church
and listen to some guy up there going
and then he did
something and he did something else
he did it for you he died painfully i
hope you appreciate it
hallelujah hallelujah
you're not [ __ ] worthy we want you to
remember this
you're a piece of [ __ ] you better hope
he's not
mad at you hallelujah
hallelujah i mean who the [ __ ] wants to
sit there through that
i mean they're still telling stories
about lepers can we [ __ ] update it
you know the world was flat now the
world is flat
and there was some lepers
and a guy in a big boat he stuck some
animals on
what am i singing i don't even know
i shouldn't have listened to my mother
like how do you end up in that okay
here's a job
where you you're not going to be able to
ever [ __ ] another
woman again you know
well do i get a wife no you don't get
that
you're going to sit in this dorm room
with a bunch of other guys none of you
are beginning are going to get any [ __ ]
whatsoever
okay there you go there's a natural like
the whole thing is just like as far as
the catholic way
is just like just flogging yourself
do you understand how [ __ ] up that you
got one [ __ ] life
you should be out having the time of
your life you know not hurting anybody
but having the time your life and
enjoying it because you [ __ ] deserve
it
because you were lucky enough to be born
a human being and not a [ __ ]
fly what if reincarnation is true
all right and you're gonna [ __ ] come
back is is a uh
i don't know something a snake eats
one of those little [ __ ] lizards
sitting there darting around
even if you don't get eaten by a snake
you only live like 14 days
you can [ __ ] drive a car you know
you can't never see a lizard doing that
[ __ ] do you oh jesus this asbestos
[ __ ] with me
um hey everybody guess where i'm going
this week i'm in beautiful downtown
[ __ ] los angeles
enjoying my life right now in this
wonderful weather you know you're
probably thinking like hey bill last
thing you want to do is go to wisconsin
in michigan
and you know what i say [ __ ] you that's
exactly where i am going
i'm going to wisconsin the great state
of wisconsin
and i'm then going on to michigan i am
doing a bunch of shows this week and as
you can tell by how long it's taken me
to tell you this i'm opening my website
i'm going to be at the barrymore
theater in madison wisconsin on march
7th uh with uh opening act wisconsin's
own
nate craig his triumphant return to the
greater madison wisconsin
area um on march 8th i will be doing not
one but two shows
at the legendary beautiful absolutely
gorgeous pabst theater
in milwaukee wisconsin um
if you live in that area and you've
never been to the theater you know you
might you should come down
see this at the very least just look at
the uh the beautiful etchings on the
wall
on march 9th i will be doing the
uh i'll be at fountain street church in
grand
rapids michigan part of the uh there's a
comedy festival out there i don't have
the name of it on my website march 9th
uh and march 10th i will be
uh right outside of detroit at the royal
oak music theater for not one but two
shows
on march 10th so that's it that's the
deal
i'm gonna visit winter for four days and
it's going to be a great time
and if you guys know any any great
places to eat
out there places you know [ __ ] that i
should definitely get
you gotta get yourself a horseshoe have
you had juicy luffy whatever the [ __ ]
you have out there a sandwich a drink a
[ __ ]
buffalo wings whatever you got i want to
know um
all right that's it where the hell are
we
55 minutes in i can't stop this early
oh okay let me tell you this story here
uh last night
i had a i did this great thing this this
um
what the [ __ ] is my phone i lose my
phone already
you guys like me do you lose your phone
like [ __ ] 20 times a goddamn day
what's the deal with your moon um
what am i trying to say okay last night
uh this [ __ ] goddamn thing
enough already last night i did a uh
this guy wayne comedian wayne fetterman
does this great
film festival every year and he picks
like four or five comedians and they all
basically talk about a a film that
influenced them as a comedian or just
wanting to get into show business or
whatever
and uh they had the comic talk about it
before and then they show the movie
and um the night i was down there nick
crowe
went down and he did raising arizona
i'm sitting in the crowd in the movies
just [ __ ] killing and i'm laughing
having a great time whatever i go down
the street
and uh i picked the uh i picked the
dirty dozen
you know i loved that movie i loved uh
victor franco
i just i just loved that the attitudes
that the dirty dozen guys had where they
just kind of i don't know appealed to me
as a kid like they did
they they were fighting it like uh they
they had issues with authority
you know i didn't like teachers i didn't
like my parents going hey get in there
clean up your [ __ ] room i just never
liked it
so the movie appealed to me and what i
didn't realize is that movie is a
hundred
and fifty minutes long so if anybody
only five people walked out we started
the [ __ ] movie
i don't know when we started we the show
was supposed to start at 10 15. i know
it may it had to have started a little
bit late we did do a q a which was a lot
of fun
and i don't know when the movie started
but it it
it ended at like 10 past one in the
morning
and i was sitting in the back and i
literally felt like it was my movie and
it was bombing people still
enjoyed it because it was you know it's
movie festival
it's like movie geeks and that type of
thing but my apologies to anybody
there who wanted to leave but didn't
want to be rude
because i was sitting there in the back
just for to be empathetic my ass fell
asleep too
i can't bel i never remember it being
that [ __ ] long
the middle of that movie the whole thing
where they have the war games i mean i
think they shot that in real time they
could have done that so much quicker
um 150 what is that two hours
30 that's two and a half hours long
um but anyways i i had
you know i kept wanting to leave out of
embarrassment because i just kept
feeling like everyone was
getting tired and they weren't enjoying
it but i was also going like wait i get
to see the dirty dozen on a big screen
so uh but
wayne assured me that everybody had a
great time they loved the movie
and uh i don't know it was
it was definitely a fun time so if
you're ever out here in la this time of
year i guess every year wayne fetterman
does it at the silent movie theater on
fairfax avenue and i think that's about
it ladies and gentlemen
that is the podcast for this week um
like i said i'll be in wisconsin and
i'll be in michigan if you guys know of
any places to eat out that way that i
should check
out uh i try to stay out of trouble when
i'm on the road but if there is a great
bar
that you know of maybe uh i'll check one
out
like grand rapids what is there to do in
grand rapids
i don't know that i've been out to that
one whatever you guys will figure out
that's a podcast for this week
go [ __ ] yourselves oh lastly
last thing i have here sorry the
asbestos is kicking in
i finally have the hard copy i'm
literally making the shape of a dvd
like one of the corners with my hand for
some reason in front of my face so i can
find the word in my asbestos logged head
um i finally have the hard copy versions
of uh my my special that came out last
year you people are all the same
um i'll be selling those
in uh wisconsin and in michigan
i already signed all of them and shipped
them out through stamps.com
and uh every show after this i will be
selling those [ __ ] because i
got about
200 boxes of them sitting in my garage
taking up space
so uh if you want to buy the uh hard
copy version of it come out to my show
and eventually we're going to get them
up hopefully sooner rather than later on
the website
and um i i really appreciate it if you
buy one
and if you don't if you've already
downloaded one whatever thanks for
listening and all that [ __ ] all right go
[ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week
you